l'ordre du jour appelle la question
orale de Monsieur Louis Duvernois à
Madame le Ministre de la Culture et de
la Communication vous avez la parole
monsieur
collègue merci monsieur le
président
madame la ministre de la Culture et de
la Communication madame la ministre
déléguée chargée des Français de
l'étranger mes chers
collègues au cours de mes différentes
missions à l'étranger
je suis très souvent interpellé par nos
compatriotes
expatriés sur l'impossibilité pour eux
de télécharger numériquement des
ouvrages édités en France et toujours
soumis au régime des droits d'auteur
ainsi l'article
11.2 des conditions de téléchargement
des livres numériques de la
Fnac à titre
d'exemple précise que les fichiers de
livre numérique proposé dans le cadre de
l'offre de livre numérique sont réservé
aux clients résidants sur le territoire
français à la date
d'achat nos compatriotes s'interrogent
sur la légalité de cette clause de toute
évidence cette attitude constitue un
frein à la diffusion de biens culturels
français et peut également plus
largement s'analyser en une atteinte au
rayonnement de la culture et de la
langue française dans le monde
en conséquence madame la ministre de la
Culture et de la
Communication
voudriez-vous nous faire savoir si les
différents éditeurs nrepassent pas leur
droit en limitant au seul résident
français la possibilité d'accéder aux
ouvrages récents ce qui est
manifestement injuste envers les
français établi hors de
France serait-il juridiquement possible
de l'étendre à tous ceux qui hors du
territoire national manifeste un réel
besoin de France comme je peux le
constater dans tous mes déplacements je
vous en remercie merci mon cher collègue
la parole est à Madame Aurélie
philippetti ministre de la Culture et de
la
Communication merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Sénateur
évidemment le Gouvernement partage
toutes vos préoccupations concernant la
la diffusion des livres français à
l'étranger et en particulier à
destination de nos compatriotes qui sont
établis hors de de France les
limitations que ceuxci rencontre parfois
lors de l'acquisition de livre peuvent
avoir plusieurs origine d'abord elles
peuvent résulter de la titularité même
des droits c'est-à-dire qu'un éditeur ne
peut avoir les droits sur un un texte
que pour son territoire et je pense
particulièrement à la question des
traductions et des illustrations qui
sont incluses dans certains livres elles
peuvent aussi être la la conséquence de
difficultés technique parfois parce
qu'il peut arriver que le revendeur ne
sache pas gérer les les différents actes
d'accès selon les pays ou de difficultés
fiscales puisque les contraintes
fiscales diffèrent d'un pays à l'autre
le coût de de maintenance d'un système
qui prend en compte cette disparité peut
parfois excéder les retours attendus de
la distribution d'où les contraintes
d'accès pour nos
compatriotes enfin elles peuvent aussi
provenir de stratégies commerciales
particulières et on sait il y a des
ventes par zone géographique des ventes
conditionnées à la présence de points de
vente physiques locaux le marché du
livre numérique et encore trop peu
développé sur certains territoires et
cetera et cetera bref toutes les
techniques numériques même si elles
offrent de grande facilité dans dans la
disposition des livres auprès de nos
compatriotes et dans leur diffusion la
plus large et de l'intérêt à la fois des
auteurs des éditeurs mais aussi bien sûr
des lecteurs mais n'est pas encore
complète
et je tiens à attirer votre attention
sur le fait que je confiererai
prochainement une mission sur la
numérisation du patrimoine écrit il faut
toutefois être conscient que les
limitations que vous avez évoqué
lorsqu'elles existent ne concernne pas
spécifiquement les éditeurs et les
revendeurs français ni même seulement le
livre ell trouvent aussi leur origine le
plus souvent dans un coût de
distribution qui est supérieur au au
retour attendu mais cette mission sur la
numérisation des textes doit permettre
d'aborder les différents moyens
notamment de lever les les obstacle à la
à la diffusion des textes auprès de nos
compatriotes à
l'étrangeréeur merci mon cher
collègueouz de la réponse